Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, you guys submitted
a lot of good questions for my Episode 2 Q&A.
I’m almost done moving too so eventually
this will all look like I’m not making these
videos from limbo or something.
You guys picked up on a lot of good easter
eggs I missed.
And lots of good Missy and Danny Pink theories.
Let’s get in it, careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven’t seen it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
1 - Action vids asks Why didn’t the Dalek
recognize the Doctor?
All because of the regeneration.
His memory banks only went up to Matt Smith.
There was a little confusion because of souffle
girl Clara erasing the doctor from their collective
memory and then the Daleks re-learning about
him in the christmas special after assimilating
Tasha Lem.
The Daleks have independent minds, the khaled
mutants do.
But they also have the machine parts with
data banks that record and distribute new
memories each individual dalek picks up.
Rusty rejoined the Dalek Fleet at the end
of the episode so it’s possible he withheld
new information about the Doctor.
I think they’ll follow up on it at some
point.
2 - Walking Who asks What do you think of
Danny Pink’s Story so far?
I like him a lot, we haven’t gotten a long
Danny Pink episode yet, so I’m withholding
a lot of comments till then.
There were pictures from the set of people
connected to him.
I think Episode 4 is supposed to add a lot
of backstory.
Like I said in my review, Samuel Anderson
does a good job of going from funny to dark
in a heartbeat, he’s not quite as grand
as Capaldi but I think being able to turn
on a dime like that is really important for
Doctor Who stories.
As far as new characters go I think he’s
an interesting new flavor, there are going
to be a few more new characters we haven’t
met yet.
I think they did a great job casting them
all so whatever their stories are I’m sure
they’ll be interesting and fun.
3 - Tigerblood asks Do you think "Rusty" will
be a returning character?
Definitely, it felt like Moffat created something
so unusual in this “good” dalek that it
would be a complete waste to not use the opportunity
to throw a wrinkle into all future Capaldi
Dalek stories.
Rusty is the new Handles.
What I’d really like to see is a Rusty scene
several episodes down the road where he comes
back with his own armada.
Like Rusty has started converting other Daleks
to his cause bit by bit.
Then rides in like the cavalry to help the
Doctor in a moment of need.
I think it will have something to do with
the Missy plot, when it comes to whatever
the final conflict is in the finale.
I’m always a fan of enemies working together
as friends for a brief period.
And the Daleks are the Time Lords greatest
enemies.
Unless you consider the Time Lords to be their
own worst enemies.
4 - Davijoman asks Do you think that Missy
will snag everyone that dies in all the episodes?
So that they all can appear with her in the
finale.
She has shown up in consecutive episodes so
it does seem that way.
I do think the circumstances of a person’s
death is important to being snatched.
It’s still a bit unclear as to what part
of each person she’s snatching.
Life Force, full on teleportation at the moment
of death or if it’s a Silence in the Library
situation, where copies are made of people.
It seems pretty clear that she wants to win
people over with very sinister kindness and
going so far as to call her domain Heaven
be it TARDIS or be it Pocket Universe, makes
it sound like she’s got plans for the Doctor
that require all those people.
If she wanted to kill him she wouldn’t have
called him her boyfriend and she wouldn’t
have said she’d keep the scottish accent.
So the question we need to ask is, what does
she want to help the doctor do that requires
an army?
I’ve spent a lot of time talking about Series
8 and broken promises.
But what if Missy is collecting people as
a way of fulfilling a promise to the Doctor.
It would be an interesting twist if everyone
the doctor considered close to him broke his
trust, but the sinister person was the only
one who didn’t break a promise.
Then there’s the question of what that promise
might be.
I love how Capaldi’s doctor has so many
questions and works everything out by lecturing
to himself using a chalkboard.
That should be his catchphrase, just “Question?”
5 - Benjamin asks, if Heaven is like the TARDIS
then shouldn’t the dead soldier have been
tiny when she woke up?
Very interesting, yes.
Missy’s garden does look a lot like a TARDIS
console.
If it is, you would think they’d still be
small after she materialized it around them.
I think it’s more evidence that she’s
only saving parts of people.
It’s still unclear whether it’s just their
consciousness.
Like a Silence in the Library situation or
if it’s their soul or life force.
Those are things we’ll need more missy scenes
to figure out.
Right now she’s only been on screen for
a few moments.
All that is clear is that she is very similar
to the Doctor and they have a history together.
6 - Alex asks do you think Danny Pink would
leave the show if Clara left or would he stay
as a companion?
I think he would stay, someone in the comments
said Samuel Anderson claimed he wasn’t a
companion in an interview but it could just
be misdirection.
The Doctor will not travel for a whole series
without a companion.
There might be episodes where we don’t see
companions, but the foundation of the show
is that The Doctor travels with someone or
something.
It wouldn’t be doctor who if he didn’t
have someone besides himself to listen to
him.
If Jenna and Samuel Anderson are both leaving
by the christmas special I think we’d also
see a teaser for who the next official companion
is in that episode.
So regardless of what happens, all questions
will be answered by the special.
We still don’t even know what the title
is, last year they didn’t shoot Matt Smith’s
christmas special till around this time in
the year.
So we might get some new info over the next
several weeks.
7 - Sandrine asks Do you think that the missy
situation will trigger darker instincts in
the Doctor like the Time Lord Victorious moments?
I think it would be really cool if the Missy
plot became a huge callback to the moment
in episode 1 where the robot asked, do you
have it in you to kill me doctor?
Like Missy will force the Doctor to kill her.
That would be as dark as the show could go.
All of episode 2 was about the Doctor showing
himself to be a good Dalek.
He’s going to continue to wrestle with his
dark passenger.
For those that watched Dexter.
I think Doctor Who as a series will always
end things on a note of closure even if we’re
crying during the finale.
So I don’t think the Doctor would completely
trash his motto.
“Never cruel or cowardly.
Never give up, never give in.”
I think killing Missy would be the cowardly
act.
8 - cajun asks Will Souffle Girl Clara turning
into a Dalek be important to anything going
on in series 8?
I think the Impossible Girl persona will be
referenced, but I don’t think that specific
version of Clara will play a critical role.
Regardless of which Clara explanation you
believe, like which version of Clara she is
right now, be it a copy or the original.
I think that’s pretty much done with.
I think all future references to multiple
claras will be jokes or subtle references
the characters make, like clara making fun
of herself.
I don’t think it’s going to play a huge
role in the missy storyline.
Keep your eyes peeled for references the other
claras, but I think they’ll just be that,
winks to series 7b.
9 - Dova Kain asks, when the doctor healed
Rusty and we saw the crack in the wall was
the root cause, did it have anything to do
with the timelords?
I think that was a visual reminder about the
time lords, but I don’t think the time lords
or the real cracks in the universe had anything
to do with Rusty.
When the doctor was showing him his memories
there were a lot of flashbacks to different
moments in doctor who history.
But I don’t think the physical cracks in
the universe were there to purposefully alter
rusty.
If the time lords wanted to contact the doctor
again, they probably would have done it in
a more direct way.
I think Rusty was an anomaly that the doctor
just seized on.
I know Moffat also writes Sherlock and on
that show, Benedict Cumberbatch’s character
says there is no such thing as coincidences,
the universe is rarely so lazy.
So I’ll say it is possible that the cracks
in the universe are somehow related to Rusty.
But I think Rusty’s story will be much less
complicated than that.
It’s Danny Pink, Clara and Missy that are
the complicated ones.
10 - Zombiestabber asks How do Daleks reproduce?
There are a couple of things they do, primarily
they just clone themselves.
But over time as their genetic templates degrade
and they assimilate new more advanced beings.
They update the template.
Changing the template was something that happened
in series 5.
The new Dalek Paradigm re-booted their genetic
code to it’s original khaled mutant state.
Those daleks showed up in a tie-in video game
but they were later retconned out of the series.
The Daleks we met in Asylum are the most current
version, those are the ones that we also saw
in the christmas special.
From a reproductive standpoint, they’re
just the same old daleks.
I think all the converted humans and Oswin
Dalek were one-offs.
Fun fact: If you consider the novels to be
canon, then the time lords also reproduce
in a similar non-traditional way.
They use something called the Loom, a device
developed by Rassilon to resequence Old Time
Lord DNA and weave new Gallifreyans into existence.
I should say that’s how they reproduce on
gallifrey, because not all people on gallifrey
are time lords.
There’s a theory that the doctor was created
from the re-sequenced DNA of The Other, the
third being that founded the Time Lord society
with Omega and Rassilon.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions,
like I said I’m almost done with my move
so my video schedule should be back to normal
soon.
My next Doctor Who video will post Saturday
morning, that will be my bonus video for favorite
fictional characters brought to life inside
the show.
Congrats to this week’s giveaway winner,
Merrinatrix you win an amazon giftcard.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
Next round of the giveaway starts when I post
my episode 3 review.
I’m also doing a game of thrones giveaway
too if you want to enter that it will start
when I post my Telltale Games Game of thrones
explainer video tonight.
If you’re just now finding me be sure to
subscribe to get everything.
Right now you can catch up on which episodes
are coming by clicking here and click here
for my episode 2 review and easter eggs.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!